most addicts don't want to die they
injected themselves with no one else
around they didn't want to die they
shouldn't die fatal overdoses from
opioids in the United States have
increased about two hundred and fifty
percent since 2007 and opioids now make
up over two-thirds of all overdose
deaths the problem is particularly acute
in a handful of states including
Pennsylvania which has the third highest
overdose death rate in the country in
the city of Philadelphia overdose deaths
are concentrated in the neighborhood of
Kensington which is the epicenter of the
city's opioid crisis but advocates here
are now planning to open a so-called
supervised injection site targeted not
just at helping addicts break their
addiction but at keeping them alive as
they continue to use and the federal
government has sued to stop them from
opening
[Music]
safe injection sites are a way of making
better use of a drug called naloxone
often known by the brand name narcan
which is remarkably effective at
stopping overdoses as they're occurring
opioid molecules bind to the receptors
that control respiration during an
overdose breathing can slow or stop
entirely this can lead to severe brain
damage or as fixation and death narcan
binds to the opioid receptors in the
brain displacing any present opioid
molecules it can rapidly reverse the
effects of an overdose in as little as
two minutes though it has no side
effects narcan is hard to come by it's
not available over-the-counter and in
some states doctors aren't allowed to
prescribe it to someone who doesn't
intend on using it themselves Philly's
supervised injection site would be a
place where addicts can use drugs in the
presence of medical professionals ready
to administer narcan to abort an
overdose the facility will also provide
clean needles and a sanitary environment
the project is called safe house and
it's rumored that organizers are
planning to located in this nondescript
warehouse on a side street in Kensington
that's littered with needles safehouse
would be the first supervised injection
site in the United States operating out
in the open but in 2014 a social service
agency opened a covert facility in an
undisclosed urban neighborhood in the US
according to a 2017 study in the
American Journal of Preventive Medicine
over two years 2574 injections were
performed at the site ninety percent of
which would have otherwise occurred in a
public restroom street park or parking
lot according to participant two
overdoses were treated immediately with
narcan there are over 120 supervised
injection sites across the globe safe
house is modeled after insite a
supervised injection site in Vancouver
Canada founded in 2003 insite has played
a key role in studies of the efficacy of
harm reduction techniques offered by
supervised injection sites it is not
lawful to facilitate the illegal use of
drugs projects like safe house however
are in violation of the so called crack
house statute which was part of the
federal anti-drug Abuse Act of 1986
we don't supply anybody with drugs we
don't touch drugs none of our personnel
do IDI rondell who's both a former
governor of Pennsylvania and former
mayor of Philly sits on the board of the
nonprofit that's behind safehouse and
he's been instrumental in building
support for the project a lot of those
people are their twenties and if they
straighten out and get treatment and get
off the addiction I think you're going
to do wonderful things for themselves
for their families for us as a society
according to the law it's illegal to
maintain any property for the purpose of
manufacturing distributing or using any
controlled substance violators can be
sentenced up to 20 years in prison and
face a fine of up to half a million
dollars it never really was meant to be
illegal the senators and congressmen who
developed the crack house statute never
in a million years thought about
volunteer medical personnel standing by
while someone injected themselves ready
to reverse the effects of the overdose
do you think they thought for a minute
that that activity should be criminal of
course not in early 2019
the Department of Justice preemptively
sued safe house and its executive
director Janette balls to make it easier
to begin making arrests if the project
moves forward we're asking the federal
government to use their prosecutorial
discretion and not make an arrest for a
violation of a statute that never meant
to cover this type of activity we'll go
ahead with it and maybe we'll end up in
federal prison it's not the first time
Rendell has squared off with authorities
for policies intended to help addicts in
1992 when he was mayor of Philly a group
of activists opened a needle exchange
called prevention point to combat the
AIDS epidemic when Rendell signed an
order allowing it to proceed he received
a call from the state health
commissioner who said he would be
arresting anyone involved with the
program I said mr. secretary come to 212
City Hall and arrest me first
prevention point went on to be a great
success our model is used in 30 other
American cities and the Congress when I
had
legalized the operation of prevention
Rendell see safe house is a continuation
of that same mission before they're
allowed to inject it in the presence of
medical personnel before they're allowed
to get a shower it said after listen to
a social worker and talk to them about
treatment options safe house countersuit
citing moral and religious imperatives
for the opening of the facility the case
is still pending but Rendell and the
other board members are dead set on
opening safe house regardless of the
outcome I don't think the government
should be wasting resources arresting
doctors and nurses who are volunteering
their time I don't think they should do
that all we want to do is save some
young people from
from dynasty
that's all we want to do
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]